france 24 on écoute tout de suite
richard ferrand qui est en train de lire
un message des bagnoles macron à
l'assemblée nationale le 18 de la
constitution j'ai décidé d'adresser un
message au parlement dont vous voudrez
bien donné lecture à l'assemblée
nationale le vendredi 25 février à 14h30
voici les termes du message du président
de la république
mesdames messieurs
face à l'évolution de la situation en
ukraine
j'ai souhaité mme adressé ce jour au
parlement
vous comprendrez que ma première pensée
dans les heures tragiques que nous
vivons va au peuple et aux autorités
ukrainiennes
je salue le courage dont ils font preuve
pour résister aux offensives militaires
massives de la russie ainsi que leur
détermination à défendre
leur souveraineté et leur liberté
rien n'a été ni ne sera négligé pour
leur venir en aide
nous leur devons soutien et solidarité
toutes les dispositions sont également
prises pour assurer la protection de nos
compatriotes en ukraine
la nation par ma voix salut celles et
ceux qui continuent d'assurer en dépit
du danger
notre représentation diplomatique
et notre soutien à l'ukraine
la crise actuelle vous le savez est née
de la décision
planifiez décider puis organisé par la
russie d'envahir l'ukraine
l'enchaînement des faits au cours des
dernières semaines est clair et sans
appel
l'accumulation de forces militaires
russes aux frontières russes et
biélorusses de l'ukraine la
recrudescence brutale
du nombre de violations du cessez le feu
et les provocations sur la ligne de
contact dans l'est de l'ukraine
'l'annonce par la russie de la
reconnaissance unilatérale est illégal
de l'indépendance des deux républiques
autoproclamées
de donetsk de lougansk en bafouant
explicitement les accords de minsk 2
février 2015
la décision d'envoyer dans les
territoires tenus par les séparatistes
des forces armées russes pour une
prétendue mission de maintien de la paix
puis le déclenchement le 24 février 2022
d'une attaque armée de grande intensité
contre l'ukraine
avec nos partenaires européens et nos
alliés nous avions anticipé cette
possibilité funestes d'une guerre sur le
continent
nous avons par conséquent tout mis en
oeuvre pour éviter l' escalade et
oeuvrer à résoudre la crise par le
dialogue
à l'étroite coordination avec l'ukraine
nos partenaires européens et nos alliés
nous avons poursuivi le dialogue
exigeant
engagé depuis plusieurs années avec la
russie car nous savons de personnes sur
notre continent n'avait rien à gagner à
l' escalade nous avons fait des
propositions sérieuses et agit sans
relâche pour mettre en place les
conditions de ce dialogue avec
l'allemagne dans le cadre du format
normandie ainsi qu'avec nos alliés et
partenaires sur les garanties de
sécurité sur le continent européen
nous constatons aujourd'hui que la
russie tournant le dos à ses engagements
et à la voie diplomatique
fait le choix de la confrontation
déstabilisatrice pour l'ensemble du
continent
par ces décisions unilatérales et ses
actions militaires la russie contrevient
à ses engagements internationaux
et remettre en cause le principe
cardinal du respect de la souveraineté
et de l'intégrité territoriale des états
le fondement même de l'ordre européen et
international dans ce contexte en tant
que membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies et au titre
de sa présidence en exercice du conseil
de l'union européenne
le devoir de la france est triple
d'abord ne rien céder sur les principes
fondamentaux de la paix et de la
sécurité collective en sanctionnant
fermement leurs violations
c'est ce que le conseil européen a acté
hier par une série de sanction inédite
touchant la russie et la bio biélorussie
les sanctions concerneront également
des personnalités ruche y compris les
plus hauts dirigeants de la fédération
de russie
ensuite il nous faut agir en solidarité
et en soutien au peuple et aux autorités
ukrainien
nous accorderons ainsi une aide
budgétaire supplémentaire de 300
millions d'euros nous sommes également
en contact avec les autorités
ukrainiennes pour leur fournir le
matériel défensif dont elles ont besoin
enfin nous devons assurer l'unité avec
nos partenaires européens et nos alliés
pour protéger notre souveraineté notre
sécurité et nos démocraties à cet égard
nous prendrons des engagements
supplémentaires dans le cadre de l'otan
afin de protéger le sol de nos alliés
baltes des roumains et nous renforcerons
la lutte contre les manipulations de
l'information et les attaques cyber pour
nous protéger contre les ingérences
étrangères
la guerre a dû traîne marque un tournant
géopolitique historique majeur du 21e
siècle et fait courir le risque d'un
retour des empires et des conflits de
frontières
cette crise majeure aura des
conséquences sur nos vies notre économie
et notre sécurité
les sanctions ont un impact dans la
durée elles ne sont jamais sans
conséquences y compris pour nous mais
nous l'assumons car c'est de la défense
de nos valeurs dont il s'agit nous
prendrons à cet égard toutes les
décisions nécessaires
afin de protéger nos compatriotes
et nos entreprises
cette épreuve vient confirmer à chacun
que notre europe n'est pas une union de
consommateurs mais bien ce projet
politique de citoyens attachés à des
valeurs et principes communs c'est à ce
titre que l'union européenne
doit pleinement devenir une puissance
plus souveraine en matière énergétique
technologique et militaire
je sais qu'au delà des divergences qui
vous oppose légitimement et qui
garantisse la vitalité de notre
démocratie
le parlement saura répondre dans l'unité
autour des principes fondamentaux
inscrits dans notre constitution la
souveraineté la liberté et le respect du
droit international
vive la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]